okay so let's continue with our
statistical approach to estimating a
constant basic basic thing our basic
setup is that uh we have uh we have some
some data that we that we measured and
we
can we assume that all this data is
coming from the normal dist distribution
with the with some mean with some
constant mean and with some standard
standard deviation but we don't know
these numbers we just assume that this
is this is happening and uh what we said
last time is uh uh with this knowledge
we can start constructing well we can
recall our good old known probability
density function the PDF which uh says
how like is to observe y k if we know if
we would know the mean and the standard
deviation and we have a sister function
of the PDF which is this capital L
called likelihood function and that just
swaps the argument yeah so if the
argument here uh is is the YK then these
two guys the mean and the standard
deviation are the parameters and we we
swap it so now we are we can ask How
likely is it uh is this value of mean
and this value of standard deviation if
we just observed this point if we just
measured 1.6 or 1.1 yeah and we we can
get this for all the all the data which
means we have this several values of
this of this
function and if we use the joint
probability we can even say well this
all these uh data YK they are coming
from the same same process they are they
are describing the same two parameters
the mean and the standard deviation so
the joint probability would be just
given by the by the product of this
likelihood uh
functions so far so good
it would be better if we don't have this
hammering now but yeah good so let's do
some some optimization this uh this
function L well we have it we have it
written here it's our our good old
gausian uh
gausian PDF probability density
function so let's do the let's do the
optimization let's try
let's try to do the
maximization Y Bar Sigma and now we have
uh the
product k equal
to one until until n and what do we have
there first there is this normalization
constant 1/ Square < TK of
piun and the sigma
and then we have the exponential term
the exponential term would be e to
the
minus we need to have
our data points y k Min - the Y
Bar squared divided by
[Music]
2 Sigma squar
H so if we if we for example uh want to
do something about this uh like solving
this optimization
problem of course what we can do is uh
well how do we solve the optimization
problems find the gradient of this of
this function and uh equalize it or make
it equal to zero find out where where do
we get the
extreme but we have the product here
yeah and it's not not very pleasant
thing uh to to do the differentiation
with the with the products yeah but the
product rule uh one differentiated times
the other undifferentiated and the other
here would mean like the N minus one
terms undifferentiated so hm what if
there was some some trick is there some
some trick which which we can pull from
our uh Magic head it won't be a rabbit
but it won't be some transformation that
can help
us so the products yeah we have there we
have a multiplication so we have a * B
so what
if ah let's write it better so a *
B can I get
something can I have some
transformation that will that will do
this yeah some something is something is
missing there from the products I get
the the summation
[Music]
exactly right so if we take a logarithm
a * B we
get logi a logarithm of a plus logarithm
of B very
good sounds now that okay okay we just
now we are just now messing with this uh
with this logarithmic uh logarithmic
function maybe I should write uh WR Ln
to to have the to have the natural
logarithm because it also will will come
in handy we have the we have the
exponential function here so of course
we know that if we take the Ln of e to
the X we just get the X back
yeah so the logarithm might be might be
the right right thing to do so let's
first apply the apply the the
logarithm and uh and see what we
get so we still have the
maximization so basically if we if we
take the take the logarithm then we
change the product this Capital pi to to
the capital Sigma to the to the
summation okay from one to
n but inside now we need to need to
write the the
logarithms uh let's first put
the yeah let's let's start with
the we're just taking the
logarithm as as it is
and then we can apply it to
the yeah and then then we can we can
apply it
farther so far so good
yeah okay well we have again here a
logarithm and we have again some
multiplication so we can we can quite
quite nicely quite nicely
continue the logarithm Rule still or
this identity still
holds so we get
the okay let's keep it like this for for
a
while
okay logarithm of the of the first term
and the logarithm of this of this second
term but we already have our identity uh
being being applied yeah
this this guy here so our e just now
nicely magically
disappears so we just
get y k minus Y Bar squar / 2 2 Sigma
squ looks already already kind of kind
of more
pleasant and
um now maybe we can we can do maybe we
are more more used to the to the
minimization than the than the
maximization it doesn't matter much in
this in this case but it would just uh
just turn out turn out to be to be to be
uh nicer to do the differentiation
later uh maybe one comment to that uh we
applied the the the the logarithm to the
objective function in the in the
optimization problem did we change the
location of the of the
optimum that's what I wanted to ask
because I can't understand how we could
just
put different okay okay good question so
so which which side you are we we cannot
do it or or we can't do it we are doing
it so we
probably magic trick uh it's uh it's
it's Rel relatively relatively easy uh
if this if this function is monotonous
for example if it's if it's increasing
then then we are then we are completely
fine because uh what what we are what we
are doing how how do we H what is the
what is the picture too I mean I mean
the B basic basic picture is to is to is
to just plot the plot the logarithm how
it how it looks like
so what does the logar M do due to the X
we have X's starting somewhere somewhere
at at uh at
zero so our X's go like 1 2 3 4 five six
and so on yeah this increase in sequence
but what does the logarithm do well it
will take the logarithm of ah there here
is the logarithm of of one yeah that's
definitely smaller than the logarithm of
two that's definitely smaller than the
logarithm of three so we still keep the
the same same extrema it's uh actually
very similar let me switch to the to our
previous previous notes when we were
plotting this uh sorry when we were when
we were plotting this uh we try we try
to to construct this uh probability
density function
so if we apply if we apply the logarithm
so going from here here to here our our
maximum in this case our our extremes
they do not change the function looks
looks different but uh but the the
location of the extreme is is still the
same convincing but how do we know the
original function monotonous no it
doesn't have to be monotonous it's it's
it's just whatever whatever was smaller
in the original World stays smaller in
the transform world yeah it the that
that function so the function that we
are doing the transformation with that
that has to be monotonous if it's
increasing then then basically nothing
changes if it was decreasing then we
then we would need to uh put like minus
sign yeah like to to say that whatever
was smaller is now bigger and and vice
versa
okay so it's just it can be generally
used yeah
yeah
exactly
okay so what now let's let's continue it
still doesn't look as as as easy but uh
it will it will soon
become um Okay so let's do another
transformation let's transform this to
minimization and and you saw this in
your optimization class so how do how
can we do this and now this doesn't have
to do anything with the monotonicity of
the objective function or anything like
that we want maximize this function as
we want minimize Nega the negative of
the
function everybody happy with that
everybody recalls that perfect
so let's do that so we go for
minimization Sigma
the maybe we can plug in the the minus
sign all
already so the
sum from k equal to 1 until until end um
um if we make if we make this one uh
negative what can we what are what are
some other logarithm rules that we could
use uh-huh uhhuh
yeah yeah basically basically
the for example I can rewrite very very
easily uh this one analog analogously if
I say this is to the power of minus one
and there is a minus yeah because this
uh this m this minus one this inversion
would basically just just U
anihilate so now but if we are now doing
the changing this minus by transforming
from Max to Min with another minus that
becomes plus and we basically just the
just have the
logarithm logarithm of the square root
of 2 pi and and sigma
mhm yeah and it should
be ghosts are coming to the
party okay and well we we complete our
uh multiplication by minus one of the
objective function and we start to see
here something very very
similar something that we we've actually
already already seen uh in our
optimization based approach right we
said well let's just minimize the the
sum of squares so let's find the Y head
which minimizes the sum of squares
between our data and our desired
estimate and here we here we go again we
have it here in the in the numerator
denominator let's see what what purpose
it it
plays but okay it means that now we can
now we can start uh having some fun and
uh and try to find try to take our let's
call it F this this
[Music]
function so will we get with respect to
y y
bar so will we get the the the the
What will what will we get if we if we
take uh take a derivative of this uh of
this function with respect to the to Y
Bar the
same yeah for the approach yeah yeah
just well almost the same of course this
this first term doesn't involve Y Bar we
are free of uh of writing writing that
what we can what we can just uh
um maybe rewrite it in a in a different
way we get we get this this constant 1/
2 over Sigma square and uh what did we
get by
by by differentiation so we get two 2 *
y k minus y bar we can even even put
this put this minus but actually since
our left hand side is zero none of these
constants actually matter I mean these
two will will cancel cancel out that's
why it's it's usual that we will find
the one half in this kind of
Expressions it's just easier to handle
but they they do not do not matter at
the end let's just uh swipe to our
previous previous lecture yeah this is
what we are this is basically what we
are getting the sum of y y i why did I
call it I last time should be K to be
consistent sorry for that uh y i minus
minus y head some of them should be
equal to zero
we have the we have the same thing here
zero should be equal to the sum y k
minus y y bar y head
um so we we already know where it leads
yeah so we can say like the estimate of
our of our mean is the good
old sum
of some of our data points so it's not
only optimal in the terms of in the term
of Le squares it doesn't only work well
this arithmetic mean if we are just
doing some experimentation it also it's
also the statistically most probable
statistically more most likely that's
why this uh this function is called
uh where is
it where is the function Ah that's why
this function L is called likelihood
function so we just get our maximum
likelihood uh
estimate okay not uh not great not uh
not terrible we just basically got what
we somehow somehow already already knew
um there are there are now several
things where we can where we can go go
ahead uh and and use to our advantage
for example we have some information
about our about our Sigma
here so we can also do the estimate of
the sigma yeah if you if you recall it
was one of the one of the two parameters
of this uh of this likelihood function
or of this joint likelihood function we
can also also estimate that one so let's
do some let's have some farther fun with
the with the
derivatives so what
if we
now take the zero and differentiate
this this
function with respect to with respect to
Sigma
um some of the L
[Music]
let's see let's see how it how it can
work so how do we do
it maybe we should start with splitting
the two
Su okay yeah we can do it uh and and
then
what then we could we could take
constant out from the other summation
Theus
the y
k y is the
constant
so
okay and
[Music]
we
Sig one SL to Sigma oh we can we can
also so only one Sigma Sigma
Square uh I wouldn't do that because we
are differentiating with with respect to
Sigma that would create the
differentiation the the product rule
yeah that will be be Sigma times
something and well there will be you
mean you mean uh H actually what do you
mean we get only the Su
ofma and we will We
canive ah differentiate that okay yeah
yeah derive and differentiate that's
that's two two false friends so der is
differentiate
derive
is yeah yeah sure sure sure I know okay
so will be more difficult because
it's
there's function we have to
differentiate and then the inside of mhm
okay but uh if if if if it's if it
sounds um sounds hard maybe we can split
the the Len function to uh apply again
this
logarithm product identity yeah so okay
let's let's then first uh first
um write this this these two summons as
uh in in two uh big sums so let's say
this is then Ln square root of 2
pi
plus oops still we need to keep it plus
we are still in the same sum Ln of
the of the sigma right that should be
easy and then we have so as yakub says
uh we have the
sum but uh we take the this
[Music]
constant in front of the
sum one over
ah two Sigma square
or should I take the take off take one
one half also also there okay
okay somebody told me yesterday some
student if I hold some ah okay
um getting getting more educated this
semester with the with the
tablet so maybe we can do fre SS now
and yeah but I
mean exactly exactly
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's a
it's a it's a it's a good comment yeah I
should have we we we should have write
it like that it's not it's not
differentiation it's notal ah okay
okay okay
let's let's do that mm okay so I'm not
professional yet uh what I want to
write d by D Sigma wow yeah something
like
this but then we can also say okay we
need the bracket here because yeah but
well if if we if we understand what we
what we mean it's it's fine I
hope what looks like Chinese
already don't worry no it's just just
Japanese uh good so let's get rid of
this
these ugly
terms derivative of a of a sum sum of
the derivatives we so we keep our our
good
friend
sum the derivative of the
constant zero derivative of Ln X or Ln
Sigma in this
case D CH GPT what is the
sure one over Sigma and uh what do we
have here we have we have still
the we have some
[Music]
constant
plus let me make it bit more tidy here
[Music]
by making this some more
concise
good so YK minus y bar
squared divided by two and
now
get from the two mhm and uh the two
changes okay
yes yeah yeah divided by Sigma cubed
yeah okay okay getting nicer what do we
want to get out of this we want to get
get Sigma
yeah so what do we do what do we do how
do we
isolate isolate
Sigma
can get rid of the
TW and okay
will
mhm
mhm MH yeah but how we get yeah it's
it's good it's on the way there so what
how do we isolate
isolate
Sigma it's like a puzzle like a like a
ridle cross
word the last
time n
but end times is is is fine but uh well
what I what I don't like is that we have
everything in the denominator it would
be easier if it goes up to the numerator
yeah so what can we what can we do can
multiply let's ah
yes Sigma cubed so multiply
everything Sigma cubed yeah it's
shouldn't be be shouldn't be a big big
problem uh let's keep the the sum here
so this is Sigma Square now right
good then we have this constant
here oh we don't have the division
anymore mhm thanks very good
I don't
know I'm just want to move this bit
down and we have the
[Music]
sum what do we have some of
ones minus is gone two is gone okay so
can we what is the sum of
ones
[Music]
mm times n
mhm sounds
good maybe we are missing something
let's let's see and and find
out
uh there is something missing there
we'll see we'll see uh okay so how how
do how to isolate now our Sigma
Square put the
second part of the equation to the other
side the one
without
mhm I don't know how this term okay yeah
so the second
term this n here is too
much why is it
there
okay
um so we
have so we add this this last term to
both sides which means now it appears on
the left hand side and we have
the sum of Sigma
squar yeah it is the
sum sum of Sigma Square what can we say
is the sum of Sigma Square
it's the same story as the sum of ones
yeah because the sigma doesn't doesn't
depend on the on the K yeah so it's like
saying Sigma square plus Sigma square
plus Sigma square plus Sigma
square
m
which so it's only
[Music]
right wait wait wait there was something
ugly with
it this sum needs to remain
here
right we cannot take the we we cannot
cannot take take it out because it it
has the the fact of of K okay H so let's
do the
Reconstruction
reconstruction somebody needs to
remember what was the what was our
original
form
okay yeah
so YK - Y Bar SAR still divided by two
still divided by Sigma
squared okay so we need to do the
differentiation
inside inside this
sum I think this was the only only only
bad move that we
did so if we do the differentiation
uh yeah okay let's keep the
sum and now we get
our
min-2 divided
by 2 Sigma cubed yeah that's from the
differentiation and we get y k minus
Y Bar oh not squared not squared anymore
because we ah now it's squared because
it's
the it's the it's the
constant
mhm okay now if we multiply it by by
Sigma Sigma cubed what we get here we
well we get rid of the of the twos we
have the minus sign here we keep
our our bracket squared but we don't
have don't don't get this this n yeah
because that's still we we keep the
sum which means we
don't don't have this
n k is equal to one
[Music]
anything anything might be missing this
one was good we get the minus from the
differentiation the two twos in the one
in the numerator one in the
denominator cancel
out Sigma cubed vanishes because of the
multiplication should be good
yeah okay so now where are we we we can
do the we can do the same stuff except
this n is basically this the the
[Music]
sum
yeah we're getting
[Music]
there
yeah K is equal to Oneal 1 to n
this one still holds yeah we are summing
the same element n times so it's n times
Sigma so now how how how will it look so
we still have
the
[Music]
Y yeah yeah we have the sum but if we if
we now make this uh uh make this Sigma
Square alone we
get rid of the
N yeah divide it 1 over n for example
and we have sum
of y k
minus y k s mhm or
maybe maybe you know this uh
in in the in the form of so this is the
Ros in Slovak variance in in in English
maybe you will know this in the form
Sigma is equal
to square
root 1 / n
y k minus minus uh y y bar
basically it's like a almost recycled
recycled definition of what standard
deviation is or let's say what is the
what is the what is the variance
variance is the
average distance of the data from the
mean yeah this is what G gives all
always this this width to the to this
gausian gausian bell curve and our our
Sigma is basically just the just the
square root uh you might have and I'm
sure you you saw uh you might have seen
you definitely saw this kind of uh this
kind of Rel
but maybe in a slightly different
different form because H what uh what we
got got here is uh is not the not a very
good not a very good uh estimate so what
what we just just found we just did the
estimation this Sigma is now is now
telling us okay we got all
this all this all this data we got we as
estimated some mean does not have to be
at the value of one but this Sigma is
telling us the best estimate for
the for the characteristics of the of
the noise well is is is this this number
so this is how our sensor is off uh on
average and it's a bit cheating because
well we don't have a lot of data and
also statistically we already used some
some degree of freedom because we
already have the estimate of our of our
of our mean yeah we just use
this this uh this arithmetic average and
statisticians would say we already used
one degree of the of the freedom so we
we already out of these end data points
the one is already already gone
so the estimate for the for this Sigma
square is usually right like 1 / n minus
one but the but the but the rest
remains you've seen this one
right
even I remember even even from high
school we we used to we used to do some
measurements and then write some
statistics and this was the standardized
error yeah something like that sounds
familiar yes or
no okay so uh this one here with the
with the with the minus one well what
What will what will happen this minus
one will make this uh be will make this
number slightly estimate slightly bigger
right because we are not dividing by the
nend by thousand measurements we are
dividing by
99999 so it it bit it uh it gives a
slightly higher number uh it uh tries to
not underestimate the the the noise and
yeah if you want
to read read farther this is called a
Basel correction
so these are
the these are the
[Music]
two two interesting points that we can
get from this from the statistical
approach but it doesn't stop there we
can we can now start start asking the
questions that would be
related
to what we what we did here last time
last time we
we repeated thousand times the Thousand
measurements so in fact we did million
of of measurements in order to get these
statistics yeah each uh each number here
in this uh histogram book box plot was a
result of uh taking thousand samples
find finding the finding the average and
no noting noting the value and we
repeated this thousand times yeah we
called it race last
time question is whether I can already
say from taking just the Thousand
samples finding one point somewhere here
whether I can say how much this point
point is is off how what is the error of
the estimate we cannot do this uh with
uh some optimization based approach but
the but the statistics will will
reveal reveal this so there are few
checkpoints on this on this on this way
so let's
say this is about
estimation
error so we can we can ask uh well the
the simple question
is I have the
real real mean of the distrib
the the real constant that I'm trying to
trying to
estimate which I don't know but uh I
have this uh
this estimate this arithmetic
mean
um of course based on the on the
measurements that I take this difference
will will will change yeah that was the
if I sorry for that much that much
scrolling but these are quite quite
illustrative yeah if we if You observe
the the blue curve it just so so sort of
happen well what what happens so after I
don't know 20 20 measurements our
estimate was 1
1.02 and well that means our error was 0
uh
0.02 after 200 measurements our error
was let's say 0 our estimate was 0.99 so
our error was minus
0.01 and uh
it
uh it turns out that also this this
error can call it like e uh can be is uh
has some has some statistical
distribution and it has normal
distribution but the question
is what is the what is the mean of this
error and what is the what what is the
standard standard
deviation so how to know
the you can
either let's call it like
this how can we know the E bar or the
mean of
this of the of the
error can for example it's quite
practical to have this notation of the
of the expected expected value it
doesn't do anything else just finds the
mean yeah so we
cannot cannot say anything exact about
the about the error but we can find its
uh its mean and we can find later its uh
its standard
deviation okay
so how does this how does this go
um this e operator is perfectly linear
yeah so that's why we can even if we
have the if we have like a like a
summation we can very nicely very nicely
split these two terms we can say okay we
have a mean of the mean of the mean
itself
and we have
the mean of our of our
estimate the mean of mean itself so
that's just the number which stays
constant that's the constant that we
want to estimate we don't know so that's
just that's just Y
Bar that's fine and now what is
the what is now the for formula for for
our our estimate our estimate well it's
the arithmetic uh
average so one/
n yeah this guy
here and now this uh again
this expected value of operator this uh
mean applying function is uh is
perfectly
linear and well if we have constant
inside we have some summation inside
everything everything can be factored
out so we have Y Bar minus 1 over n and
the
sum and the sum of the e
y
k this one cannot be factored out that's
the that's that's the random random
variable but of course the good news is
that we know something about this about
this random variable and we know the
mean of this random
variable what's the what's the mean of
the of the random variable
very lost don't worry qu the answer is
so easy ah now I moved something which I
didn't want to move okay
good now our YK comes from from this
distribution so we know it's its mean is
going to be Y Bar
oh
simple very
simple okay so what do we have one
over Y Bar minus 1 / n sum
of Y
Bar
and we have already seen twice today and
we going to see seeing this sum where
the summons do not depend on K what is
this going going to
be n * y y y bar which means okay let's
write it down 1 / n n * Y Bar which
means Y Bar minus y
bar which means zero
okay what did we try to find out well we
try to find out what is the mean of the
of the error so if we take enough
measurements so if our number of the
measurements will be increasing our
estimate will our estimation error will
converge to zero our estimate will
converge to the True Value yeah it's a
it's a big uh
big thing it even has its name it's
called it says that the well arithmetic
mean is
unbiased oops unbiased
estimate in Slovak it's
called very nice
wording uh unbias
estimate
yeah if
the if the N goes to Infinity
our estimate our estimate will will be
uh very very close or well will be the
same as
our sorry as our true value if if we if
we do the same thing for the geometric
mean well we won't find it yeah we we
won't we we will we will find out it is
a biased estimate there will be there
will be a
certain uh C certain offset so very very
interesting very important
property and uh it doesn't stop there
because so we now now know that
this
one goes to zero if n goes to if n goes
to Infinity so that's our that's our
statistics of the estimation error and
now the question is what will be
this let's call it let's call it maybe
Sigma e the standard deviation of the of
the
error and this one is going to be bit
harder we would actually
use yeah this this
formula at some
point so now we want to
find oh let's do it like this
the variance of the estimation error
well it will be the expected value of
what expected value of uh
how
our
estimate
is
distant distant to the to the True Value
value almost the same as as we had
before this Square now now changes now
now changes
everything
um
yes is it correct let me
see because this derivation is the
hardest I don't want to don't want to
start and propagate some some
error there
if my laptop starts
cooperating no it
[Music]
doesn't Okay so let's let's let's try
this
one we need to find the mean of of this
uh of this Square so the so for the mean
we already already know what to what to
apply we should get the one over n
okay now you are
there oh okay one over and comes
later we should
first write down what is our what is our
estimate of the of the
mean good that's the arithmetic average
one over n sum of y
k and it's still still
squared okay
let's
now what we can do to make this easier
we can now uh take this one over and
out how can
we how can we take it out of the of of
this of this Square
if we have
uh okay let's say let's say we have a we
have a term term like this a minus n * n
*
B and we we want
to isolate this n in front of the in
front of this of this
bracket what should we
do how would you proceed for
[Music]
lost
okay we can for
example imagine here something like this
yeah that we have that this one here in
front of a is just written as n n by n
that means that we have already n as a
as a common common term and we
can we can uh collected in front of the
bracket so what what would we get 1 / n
n * a minus
B but this won't be won't be correct yet
what what is it
missing exactly
yeah okay so let's now
try to to apply apply this this here so
what we what we need to what we need to
make with this Y Bar well let's just uh
let's just imagine well pretty much the
same thing that we have n over n and now
we are taking taking out one over over
n from this from this uh
expression and we take it out as 1 / n
squ
[Music]
let's see what
we what we got what
remains since we got rid of 1 / n there
is one / n is is gone in front we still
have n inside the bracket for the first
term but
what we have here is
[Music]
uh sum of
YK this one is good Square just
write okay just the Cosmetic change uh
change so far and what we can do now is
uh you remember our our formulation with
uh uh if we are
summing Sigma plus Sigma plus Sigma n
times we get n
Sigma yeah what if we now now reverse it
so what would be this expression if we
want to write it with with some
summation
yeah if I if I want to want to rewrite
this one as a as a sum so Y Bar Y Bar
yeah
easy but now we can combine it with the
with the with the second second
summation which means we have we have
[Music]
YK
yeah we would be almost done here
if the only problem is is is this this
bracket ET if this bracket was here we
are fine because that's the sum of
squares we we have already seen it
derive it now we have a problem that
this is not the sum of squares this is
the square of the sum and that's not in
general the same thing yeah it's just uh
what is it a + b s is not the same as a
s + b s right we all we all know so
there are these uh there are this cross
terms a plus b in this case like y1 * y
y 2 and and so on which which will which
will make this
problematic they will make it
problematic uh in the if we
are if we are if we are not in the doing
this in the statistical sense so we are
taking the um we are taking average of
this of this expression yeah that's what
the expectation operator means and we
will have this later so we can do here a
big um big star that it's that will say
we we
require in the pen in the pen
dance which would basically mean that
the expected value of
the Y one or let's let's put
it more
generally the
the expected product of
whatever they they cannot be they uh do
not have to be even even
consecutive
no of whatever whatever two two
measurements will be will be
zero just
uh just bear with me for the moment in
the next or the or the lecture after it
we will we will we will see uh why this
holds if the if the samples are
independent what does it mean they are
indep dependent the noise is independent
so if I measure the temperature in this
room now the value that I measure will
not influence the value that I measure
in next minute in the in the in the 10
minute in the 10 minutes from from now
yeah it's a the not the noise the
current noise doesn't influence the
future noise and and and vice versa yeah
so it's relatively
uh reasonable reasonable
assumption but if we have this then we
are happy sun is shining on our side
because we can
now get e get easily read basically just
put this left square bracket inside the
inside the
sum yeah so this is
[Music]
if we want to be the influencers on on
YouTube or or Tik Tok then yeah we will
start this lecture I I show you one way
of how of of where mathematics would lie
to you and this thing is actually
actually equal yeah so and it
[Music]
is right
okay we can start we can start to
celebrate because this is already
something that we that we uh that we
know that we have
seen where have we seen it well
basically basically just just here
because
our our
variance of the of the measurement noise
well just as just as this this formula
so we have some of the of the of this
bracket to the uh the the some of the
squares divided by 1 /
n
wow this is almost it this is the this
is one over n there is one more one more
n extra which is good and now we have
the the sum of sum of squares so
basically this then becomes one over and
and
uh now let's just write it as a as
a sigma
Square okay
what does this what does this
mean we we ended this uh equal uh equal
sign and some expression equal sign and
some expression but what we started with
we were asking what is the what is
[Music]
the spread of the of the error what is
the standard deviation of the error so
for example we have now we have now this
this
result which is in terms of of variances
but let's U let's for example think
about what what it what it means Sigma
here is how much noisy our our sensor is
so how much it will uh throw our value
that we want to measure off and this is
if we take several measurements this is
how often we will be with the estimate
of this of this constant and this
relation now now now tells if we the
more samples we take the smaller our our
error gets it's not automatic it's uh
it's uh property of the arithmetic mean
again and this one again has a special
name in the statistics so it would they
would say uh arithmetic mean is uh
we had unbiased estimate and now they
would say it's
consistent what would it mean if I take
10 measurements my error would would
shrink if I get 100 measurements my
error is smaller than the one I had when
I had only 10
measurements we have already seen this I
I've been foreshadowing it uh to you
last
time remember what happened with the
with the median here this uh uh this
sudden like high
oscillations that that didn't didn't
happen to the to the to the arithmetic
mean and basically if you if you now
look at the at the arithmetic mean how
how it changes this oscillation ations
get smaller and and smaller and smaller
and also our our estimation error gets
smaller and and and and smaller and it's
always the if we have more samples we
have we have smaller smaller error so
this is the consistency of the of the
estimator if it said that our estimate
is plus minus uh is one plus -
0.05 if we take more measurements it
cannot say something like it's plusus
one yeah it cannot just say oh I was
wrong
no
okay you and well if we this is this is
done now in the in the terms of the
variances we can of course uh of course
ask like about the standard deviation
the standard deviation is the thing that
lives in the same world as our measured
quantity yeah it will if we are
measuring the temperature standard
deviation is in
kelvins so that's also relatively
relatively easy easy to find so our
error in in terms of degrees uh meters
uh bars whatever we are measuring is
improving with respect to the square
root of the of the measurements yeah so
if we want
to so let's say we have uh what
our our sensor has a standard deviation
of one and we want to have the estimate
that is that has a Precision of uh of
0.1 yeah so
what is what is the number
of what is the number of measurements
that that we should
take right yeah patri
agrees you are the patri aren't you no
okay so what's your new personality um
okay yeah so if we want to
improve improve if we want to make sense
out of the measurements that have uh
that have uh the noise with the standard
deviation of certain value in this
example one we need by by a factor of 10
we need to take at least at least 100
measur measurements it's very very good
very very practical practical
things okay
so we are we are basically done with the
with the hardest uh hardest statistics
whatever if you survive this the rest is
just the paradise yeah don't worry um so
at this point
we can we can already already say
something about uh about the
distribution of our of our error we
already characterize it we already
already
know that
our our estimation
error so
e is
uh has standard distribution with the
mean
zero yeah if we measure long enough our
estimate will be the same as the thing
we want to estimate will be true and we
have
our uh standard deviation Sigma
e
um
basically well this is nothing else than
the
standard then the standard I shouldn't
say standard let's say a classical
classical gausian gausian distribution
it's just now not on the measurements
it's on the on the estimation error and
uh as
we if we take
uh more measurements so let's say the
black situation is that we take low
number of measurements this purple
situation will be will be the one with
uh with more measurements well
we we know that our mean is is zero but
our the spread of this of this gusan
Bell will will will improve so we will
be
more more certain about about the the
mean that we that we
estimate and we can quantify this
[Music]
hope you can still you can still bear
one more one more statistical one more
statistical
distribution
um we
set well we can have
some some variable variable X um that
can be distributed with the normal
distribution and
some mean some oh sorry some standard
standard
deviation
uh what becomes more practical what what
we will uh what we will uh what we will
use is well to
know what is the the distribution so if
x is normally dist distributed then what
is the distribution of the of the X
squ you can maybe just try to try to P
picture picture this out so if
uh if x even if it has a zero mean then
the distribution is like this what would
be the distribution of the of the X X
squar well
the negative values do not play any any
role here anymore because well X squ can
cannot be cannot be negative so this
this
distribution
actually looks maybe maybe something
something like this
yeah shape shape doesn't doesn't matter
much uh
and uh this one you might have heard it
that's that one is called the key key
squared he quadrat in Slovak key key
Square uh
distribution what is nice about it is
that it can
have several
parameters
XI
Square say from from I
to let's call it lower lower case
n and that also even this sum will be
distributed as a key Square distribution
but this parameter there will be some
parameter n which will basically say how
many gausian distributed or normally
distributed variables were squared and
were summed summed together
that will come in handy later when we
have uh when we are not estimating just
one constant but several several
parameters so uh
basically basically what we can say what
we can say about
the using the key Square distribution
about our our estimation error
we
can we can say we have
our y hat we have our estimate or sorry
Y Bar so we have the true constant we
have
the the estimate of it
[Music]
we know it's its standard uh standard
deviation so this would mean that uh we
will we will just uh just Norm aliz so
this thing here would actually have zero
mean and uh and just the standard
deviation of of
one that's one
thing so if we now use the the key
Square distribution we would
get ah sorry this guy here squared so
this one is
now has now distribution of key squar
and we would say it's one because it's
just a one one value one one number that
we are estimating and then
squaring
um and what we can what we can do now if
you if you recall
our
no just one side one
side if you recall
our our statistics uh introduction well
now we have the
distribution for which we can again do
some some sort of a some sort of a
confidence confidence interval with we
can ask if we
have
the cumulative distribution function of
the of this key Square distribution we
can say I want the 95% confidence
interval give me the the
value which would which would represent
maybe this yellow
value which would represent the
how
much this squared normal variable will
be will be off of its
mean let me just write down what what I
mean
so this one will be now less or equal
yeah that was the condition in the
cumulative distribution function of
quantile of some key distri key Square
distribution uh we can we can denote it
like minus one because we are we now we
are getting this quantile or
percentile and uh we can even say this
Alpha uh as a parameter so this will be
the alpha percentage H
probability
or Alpha
percentage confidence
interval in
interal
and this is now F we have now now some
concrete concrete numbers so let's say
we
we now play with this if we take a
square root of the of the inequality
what what what should be the result if
you take uh x²
is less or equal
four what if we take the square root
what is the
uh what is the the expression that would
Express the the former inequality
yeah exactly okay so let's apply it to
our to our former expression so it means
that we
have
minus square root of this key Square
monster
don't worry the key Square monster is
just the number that we will get in in
Matlab by by one
command less or
equal Y Bar minus our
estimate divided by Sigma
e and the same key Square
monster and
let's complete this so how can we what
can we say now about
our about about the real constant that
we are trying to estimate we don't know
this number what we can get is the
estimate we can we can also also get the
standard deviation of the
estimate but we can easily find out that
this this is let's take
our our estimate
here and on the left hand side we
are
subtracting
this Sigma e square root of this key
Square
monster and on the right hand side we
are we are adding the the very same
[Music]
thing looks horrible I know I didn't
invent it but if I invented I would be
very famous um this this is how how we
can so all these all these things on the
left hand side and the right hand side
is what we can calculate from data
arithmetic average this is what what was
it if we estimate the
the uh standard deviation of the
measurement error yeah this is the one
with the square root of the number of
measurements this is a statistical
function which we just uh just get its
value from metlab so we can very easily
find find out how far is our estimate
from the from the reality so we can
basically get the interval left right
the reality is between minus 0.01 plus
0.01 for example and we know if we take
more measurements this interval will get
smaller and
smaller you survived the hardest part of
this statistical uh things any questions
to that comments
good please try to digest that during
your during your
uh during your
exercises ah where did I put the and uh
let me know what you thought of this of
this lecture thank you